-Our next guests
are two comedians
who star in the prank comedy
series "Chad & JT Go Deep,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-Perineum sunning is where
you allow direct sunlight
to penetrate your bare sphincter
for 30 seconds or more.
Dr. Drew says that the sun
is a massive electric node
in the sky --
-Mayor. Mayor.
The public speaker is allowed
to speak about something
that is within the jurisdiction
of the city of Irvine,
but this subject matter is not.
-Mr. Melching --
-This is a...
-What up, Council?
I would love to have my friend
and colleague Chad Kroeger
demonstrate the position
for perineum sunning.
If you can redirect your
attention towards the stairs.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Chad.
-Please welcome to the show
Chad Kroeger and JT Parr,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome, gentlemen.
I'm so happy to have you here.
Now, for the uninformed,
how would you describe your show
"Chad & JT Go Deep"?
-Well, Netflix basically
came to us, they were like,
"Hey, dudes, we're a big fan
of your activism.
Big fan of your message."
And they were like,
"We just want to have a camera
crew document your work."
And it ended up actually being
a pretty crazy journey.
Like, it started off
on kind of a bad note.
We accidentally got canceled...
-Yeah.
-...for a pretty major faux pas
in the racism category.
-Mm-hmm.
-Well, yeah, we were trying
to protect skateboarders
because they've been, like,
persecuted in our culture.
-Mm-hmm.
-But we didn't realize
that the phrase
"protect our boarders" was --
[borders]
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know it was loaded with
such intense connotations.
-Sure, well,
it's barely in the news.
How could you?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, like, the news, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Crazy.
-How did you guys --
If I can ask,
how did you guys first meet?
-Oh, dude, it's a good story.
So, we actually met
doing a four-hose beer bong,
the Mount Chugmore.
[ Laughter ]
Which you can get on Amazon
for $23.99.
And so, there were three
other dudes --
Landon, Reece, and Kellen --
but Reece had to sub out
'cause he was on antibiotics.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-And JT subbed in and it was
like a cosmic connection.
-Dude, yeah.
I'm just chugging to be a bro,
and then I look over,
and me and Chad just made
the most powerful eye contact.
[ Laughter ]
And we kind of haven't stopped
looking at each other since.
-Wow.
Now, you mentioned, Chad, you
refer to yourself as activists.
How would you describe or define
your activism?
-I'd say the main thing
with our activism
is the pursuit of stoke.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
You know, like, we started out
asking the city council
of San Clemente
to erect a statue
of Paul Walker.
-Mm-hmm.
-'Cause, um...
-Of "Fast and the Furious" fame.
-"Fast and Furious," yeah, yeah.
Because it was at the time,
not unlike now,
when the country is super
divided, and we were, like,
you know, "Who is a unifying
figure in our life?"
Paul Walker.
[ Laughter ]
We think that can unite
the "nayshe."
And so, it just came from there
and then we've been just
pursuing causes
just to get everyone fired up
and frothing again.
-Yeah.
Have people from the "Fast 5,"
"Fast and the Furious" franchise
reached out?
'Cause obviously,
you guys are fans.
-Yeah, actually,
we became friends
with Jordana Brewster,
who plays Mia Toretto.
And we got to go to her wedding
where she married
our main dawg Mason.
And Vin Diesel was there, and we
got to take a photo with him.
-Yeah.
He seemed so excited
to take it with you guys.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
We kind of bum-rushed him.
-And to be totally candid,
we were on a lot of mushrooms
at the time.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause I feel like
if he was down to pose
for one...
you might have taken a second
one that you were in, Chad?
-Right, yeah.
I did...yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I got a little boned
on the framing there.
-You got a little boned
on the framing.
Hey, you know,
we saw in the clip
and obviously you mentioned,
you know,
for the Paul Walker statue,
you obviously go
in front of city councils often
for your activism.
Have you reached out
to other city councils
other than sort of near home?
-Yeah, we went to Greenville,
South Carolina,
to pay homage
to the Queen who passed.
And we were a couple weeks late
'cause we had been
at a silent retreat.
But they ended up cutting me off
before I could give her
the respect she deserves.
I wanted to sing a song for her
because, you know, Princess Di
has Elton John.
I wanted Queen Elizabeth
to have Khalifa.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
But they were actually talking
about extending Main Street
by a couple blocks, so I was
a little off topic.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we actually --
we accidentally went
to the planning commission,
which deals with property.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah.
-How patient would you say
they were for you guys?
-They told me to shut up
three times.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Chad, I should note
you're also an actor --
I was talking to you
backstage --
scene-stealing in this year,
this season of "Barry."
There you are.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How did that come about?
Was that enjoyable for you?
-Oh, it was amazing.
Yeah, so, I got the audition
and then it turned into a Zoom
with Bill Hader,
who is a hero of ours
and he's just the best guy.
He's just very inspiring.
He's just so passionate
about his work and stuff.
And he's a big fan of our stoke
and our message and our wisdom.
And he's, like, basically
he's like, "Hey, dude, like,
I just want you to impart your
wisdom into the Barry universe
and let the characters know
what's up."
-I know him -- he's always been
drawn to wisdom, so it makes...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Another hero you guys met --
I believe this is a photo
of you, JT,
with Arnold Schwarzenegger.
How did you meet him?
By the way, all your --
the pictures of you guys
with celebrities are so good.
[ Laughter ]
You guys obviously have
a really good camera.
-Arnold reached out to us
and he wanted to lift.
And we were like,
"Of course," and...
[ Laughter ]
The thing about Arnold is,
is he's perpetually inspiring.
Everything he says is inspiring.
Everything about him
is contagious,
including his accent.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, he was telling us,
you know,
"During your dead lifts,
say 'I can do it.'"
Very inspiring.
And I couldn't help
but do the accent.
So in front of him I was like,
[as Arnold] "I can do it!"
[ Laughter ]
And I PR'ed.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-You PR'ed?
That's exciting.
Now, you guys, is it true...
Because you have appeared
on Fox News a handful of times.
-12.
-12 times?
-Mm-hmm.
-Is it true you've been banned?
Do you think you currently -- do
you think you'll be asked back?
-Well, what happened is, we were
speaking on a new cause
that we were really
passionate about.
And we went on there
and we told the world
that we have small penises.
[ Laughter ]
Because there's a lot of shame
around that across the globe,
and we wanted to destigmatize it
and we wanted dudes
to feel comfortable.
And in retrospect,
we probably should have
given Fox a heads-up.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What did they think
you were gonna talk --
Did they have any sense of --
-We were supposed to talk
about the Super Bowl.
[ Laughter ]
-This was our Super Bowl.
-In case anybody was wondering,
they really were.
[ Laughter ]
To be fair, based on how
professional you were dressed,
they couldn't possibly have
known something was coming.
-Yeah.
I wore my
first communion outfit.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, gentlemen,
congrats on the show,
and thanks so much
for making time for us.
That's Chad Kroeger and JT Parr.
-Thank you!
-"Chad & JT Go Deep"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."